109 soldaten und sechs soldatinnen
stellen sich der belastungs übung fünf
tage dauert sie und hat es wirklich in
sich
die herausforderung am ersten tag einen
30 kilometer langen orientierungsmarsch
von enns nach treffen in oberösterreich
durchzustehen
es tut schon weh mittlerweile interviews
also man spürt es schon jetzt endlich da
so meine frau damals zu sein
ein letztes gemeinsames antreten bevor
die dauerbelastung beginnt hoch
motiviert
endlich wieder eine belastungsphase wo
man vorher nicht weiß dass mir die
hundertprozentig schaffen will etwas
neues zum kennenlernen
wir waren ja ziemlich oft am übungsplatz
und rafting von dem her denn hier das
ist gut für die fünf dann auf der übung
und x.org aufgrund der guten
vorbereitung gut motiviert malen trägt
der soldat bis zu 30 kilo mit sich und
seinem rücken gepäck dazu kommt noch
dass die gruppe g mit zubehör mit sich
führt sandberger tun und die komponenten
ausrüstung beim komponenten und mit sich
wieder die ganze ausrüstung die ein
soldat braucht um tausende fällt eben zu
überleben dazu zählt zum beispiel das
essgeschirr für die verpflegung die mehr
zu planen geknüpft mit einer anderen
märz plane aber daraus dass die zwei
mann zelt errichten die flieger mitte
oder ein ballett oder edelweiss kappe
die thermohose das szucs gerät
wollsocken kleines handtuch
die kampfanzug sagte schweer dann
unterleibchen zu uns leibchen unterhose
mindestens eine ein rollkragen leibchen
kampf anzugsjacke leicht kam von kruse
leicht die thermo jacke hosenträger
schwere kampfanzug scapa nässeschutz
fäustlinge mindestens 2
die agrarmesse schutzmaske und abc
schutzanzügen leicht waschzeug
mindestens ein rasierschaum zahnpasta
und zahnbürste zweiten schau dir das gut
den hellen natürlich die kampf feste mit
mindestens vier magazins tasche
dass es so eine grundausstattung die
jeder auf jeden fall mitnehmen muss wir
begleiten zwei der insgesamt zwölf
gruppen auf ihrer größten hürde zum
unteroffizier bevor es losgeht noch
schnell ein erinnerungsfoto
am ersten tag der belastungs übung
müssen die lehrgangsteilnehmer eine
strecke von gut 30 kilometer mit einigen
höhenmetern bewältigen
dabei gibt es verschiedene stationen wie
zum beispiel eine furt ein gewisser
überwinden
das transportieren von verwundeten
personen und andere stationen des
weiteren kommt es vor allem darauf an
dass die lehrgangsteilnehmer richtig
orientieren und den richtigen weg finden
am mars ziel werden sie dann einen
sogenannten verfügungsrahmen beziehen wo
sie ein lager den platz für die nacht
einrichten
die erste maß distanz beträgt ca 15
kilometer breit vorgabe fünf stunden
wird die zeit nicht eingehalten scheidet
man aus erstes hindernis ein nebenarm
der donau
wir haben dort station 2 führt das ist
ein enorm von madonna ist sich 80 90 cm
tief wir haben so 13 14 15 grades ist
vom sommer hinaus angenehm worden dass
weg deshalb sehr optimal und es geht
darum dass die leute ist es eine
selbsteinschätzung der selbstvertrauen
in sich gewinnen damit sie bei
schlechteren bedingungen und generell
wissen dass das kein problem darstellt
die gegend oder kräftig ein und drüben
mit der kampf kräftig aus dazu sehen sie
die hosen aus sport show fahrsicherheits
könnten wir ja durch müll und so weiter
trennen
obwohl es ein so dass eine hand frei
haben gänger dadurch trümmern wieder
raus dass dienste wie den weitermarsch
und maschinen weiter gehören zehn
kilometer wir gehen am besten rot neue
taschenkarte angenehm für die füße
allgemeingut kräften seine erst problem
weil er ziemlich viel wiegen und auch
inhaltlich seien zum tragen 1500 die top
gun club passt gut
auch die zweite gruppe die wir begleiten
überquert schon den fluss und liegt noch
gut in der zeit
mit an bord übrigens auch zwei weibliche
teilnehmer der top damals damen beim
militär das wird nur probleme geben und
die werden sonst ist nie speziell die
belastung über habe aber schnell eines
besseren belehrt worden war
die damen können finger bleiben und
besser leiden als männer
das kann ich einfach kanal aus was sind
das nutzt so die leitung zu zögerliche
bloße möglichkeit untereinander bleibt
die heute was uns im kupfergeschäft eine
pressen
dies wird sondern sie werden sie
meistern oder zeit hatte nicht viel zeit
verschenkt prophylaxe der leider die
zeit läuft das besondere speziell für
mehr weit ist er beobachte ist das
zusammenführen der gruppen also die
gruppendynamik in web de groot es gibt
gruppen formieren sie erst richtig dort
unter dieser belastung
es gibt aber gruppen die kinder neetze
gründung geht damit aber mit masse
lernen sie speziell gruppendynamik
niedergelassen gelungen die stimmung
innerhalb der gruppen ist sehr gut also
wir reden miteinander umgehen ist sehr
wichtig weil man als anna niedriger was
man jetzt vielleicht nicht so gut aber
so bisher seien diese stimmung sehr gut
jetzt einer station dass die zeit
station beim minister die ganzen
stationen bzw kilometer bis zur nächsten
station innerhalb einer gewissen zeit
absolvieren
alle seien gut in der zeit jetzt geht es
zur nächsten station dann nochmal
mittagspause und dann geht's weiter
also war es dass man seit fast acht
stunden unterwegs sein
was jetzt nicht nachgeschaut weil umwege
gehen um mir jetzt immer noch circa
sechs kilometer bis zum nächsten punkt
und dann hoffentlich treffen gehen
solange es gut ausgeht oder ob jetzt
gilt es überhaupt kein problem
aber so wie das stück rostocker darauf
aber das war schon steil und sie zu mann
und verlinkt fonds und bewältigt mal
irgendwie dann letztendlich gewesen sein
mit den stellen steht könne aber erstmal
weiter bergauf und das mit 30 kilogramm
marschgepäck der kilometer lange anstieg
ist hart doch zugführer döhrer und ihre
kameraden kämpfen und kommen gut voran
bei einer anderen gruppe gab es bereits
den ersten zwischenfall
ein teilnehmer wurde ohnmächtig und
musste ins krankenhaus
kurz vor dem letzten anstieg auf den
pfenning berg wird nochmals energie
getankt viel zeit zum ausruhen bleibt
allerdings nichts und der anstrengendste
teil steht noch bevor
ein verwundeten transport bei nacht die
zusätzliche last um das stundenlange
maschinen ziert bereits an den
energiereserven der gruppe doch
zumindest ist die vorletzte station für
heute erreicht die gruppe erhält die
koordinaten für die nächste und letzte
station des tages dem verfügungs raum
oder schlicht gesagt dem nachtlager das
richtige orientieren hat höchste
priorität
kommt man vom weg ab mußmann
kraftraubende umwege in kauf nehmen was
zum ausscheiden der ganzen gruppe führen
kann
die gruppe erreicht vollständig aber
auch sichtlich angeschlagen das
nachtlager gut sehr gut
die gruppen haben wir meine erste klasse
oder der erste zug heraus dem gefecht
her hat jetzt die aufgabe einen gefechts
mäßige einen verfügungsrahmen zu
beziehen zu sichern zusicherung
einzusetzen
die kampf aufträge zu erteilen und sich
für die nacht herzurichten
die schwierigkeit ist natürlich unter
erschwerten bedingungen noch sagen
eigentlich stärker einmarsch in der
nacht ohne licht einen verfügung some
beziehen die kampf aufträge zu geben wo
es bei dunkelheit
erste gruppe setzt ihr ein um ein
durchsickern und bekannten personen in
den verfügungsrahmen zu erinnern
hier soll es also es tut schon weh
mittlerweile dokumentiert also mal
spielt schon jetzt endlich doch alle
froh dass mainz dort seien aus angst von
der anstrengung sachen war sicher die
sks station wo meine kameraden den
bergen müssen
und ja es war das aufwärts gehen und
dann die sonne und solistische zum
gespielt
der erste tag ist überstanden wie sich
die gruppen am zweiten tag der
belastungs übung schlagen sehen
in der nächsten folge
denken wir nur mit